the increase in quality of life that AI
can deliver is extraordinary
we can make the world amazing and we can
make people's lives amazing we can cure
diseases we can increase material wealth
we can like help people be happier more
fulfilled all of these sorts of things
and then people are like oh well no one
is going to work but
people want
status people want drama people want new
things people want to create people want
to like feel useful
um people want to do all these things
and we're just going to find new and
different ways to do them even in a
vastly better like unimaginably good
standard of living world
but that world the positive trajectories
with AI that world is with an AI That's
aligned with humans it doesn't hurt
doesn't limit doesn't um
doesn't try to get rid of humans and
there's some folks who consider all the
different problems with the super
intelligent AI system so
uh one of them is Eliza yukowski
he warns that AI will likely kill all
humans
and there's a bunch of different cases
but I think one way to summarize it is
that of it's almost impossible to keep
AI aligned as it becomes super
intelligent Can you steal man the case
for that and um to what degree do you
disagree with that trajectory
so first of all I'll say I think that
there's some chance of that and it's
really important to acknowledge it
because if we don't talk about it we
don't treat it as potentially real we
won't put enough effort into solving it
and I think we do have to discover new
techniques to be able to solve it
um I think a lot of the predictions this
is true for any new field but a lot of
the predictions about AI in terms of
capabilities
in terms of what the safety challenges
and the easy parts are going to be have
turned out to be wrong
the only way I know how to solve a
problem like this is
iterating our way through it
learning early
limiting the number of one shot to get
it right scenarios that we have
to Steel Man
well there's I I can't just pick like
one AI safety case or AI lineman case
but I think Eleazar
wrote a really great blog post
I think some of his work has been sort
of somewhat difficult to follow or had
what I view is like quite significant
logical flaws but he wrote this one blog
post outlining why he believed that
alignment was such a hard problem that I
thought was again don't agree with a lot
of it but well reasoned and thoughtful
and very worth reading
so I think I'd Point people to that as
the Steel Man yeah and I'll also have a
conversation with him
um there is some aspect and I'm torn
here because
it's difficult to reason about the
explanation Improvement of Technology
but also I've seen time and time again
how transparent
an iterative trying out
uh as you improve the technology trying
it out releasing it testing it how that
can
um
improve your understanding of the
technology
in such that the philosophy of how to do
for example safety of any kind of
Technology but AI safety
um gets adjusted over time rapidly
a lot of the formative AI safety work
was done before people even believed in
deep learning and and certainly before
people believed in large language models
and I don't think it's like updated
enough given everything we've learned
now and everything we will learn going
forward so I think it's got to be this
very tight feedback loop I think the
theory does play a real role of course
But continuing to learn what we learned
from how the technology trajectory goes
is quite important I think now is a very
good time and we're trying to figure out
how to do this to significantly ramp up
technical alignment work I think we have
new tools we have no understanding
uh and there's a lot of work that's
important to do
that we can do now